bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir quel compromis possible
sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est la priorité
absolue des français le premier test
aussi pour l'exécutif ici à l'assemblée
nationale alors avant le discours de
politique générale de main d'elizabeth
bornes on va tenter de voir très
concrètement avec nos invités ce qui
pourrait faire l'objet d'un accord entre
majorité et opposition pour freiner
l'inflation grand débat politique est un
art ans sur ce plateau notre grand
témoin incarne la jeune génération
ambitieuse à droite certains le rêve à
la tête du parti les républicains il a
été réélu haut la main à l'assemblée
nationale il incarne une ligne dure
vis-à-vis des manuels mâcon tout en
s'affirmant constructif pourrait bien
travailler est avec nous ce soir enfin 3
a franchi ce soir on va retrouver l
amont d'un gars va en direct du mobilier
national à paris c'est là que les
députés renaissance reçoivent en ce
moment même la première ministre
elisabeth bornes le parti pris de jean
rémi baudot refuser toute coalition
quelle erreur politique et puis le
voyage dans le temps de si beaux enoch
retour ce soir en archives sur ferrari
premier ministre qui n'ont pas
solliciter la confiance voilà pour le
menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs ça y est le deuxième
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron est enfin
sur les rails et c'est sur le pouvoir
d'achat que la première ministre va
devoir relever son premier défi ici à
l'assemblée bonsoir aurélien pradié non
merci d'être là députée les républicains
du lot numéro deux des républicains
on va parler tout à l'heure de l'avenir
de votre famille politique a perdu quand
même pas mal de plumes aux législatives
jusqu'où les élèves sont ils prêts à
coopérer avec la majorité eh ben on va
se le demander tout de suite sur la
question de l'inflation pour freiner les
prix de l'inflation l'envolée des prix
bonsoir on les dit elodie jacquet la
forge bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes député
modem de leader et lui il y a quelques
jours vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale vous allez nous dire ce que
les députés ensemble c'est-à-dire avec
renaissance modem et et horizons sont
prêts à faire comme geste très
concrètement sur ce texte si important
pour pour les français pour qu'il soit
voté ici même pour soir sébastien jumel
ravis de vous accueillir député
communiste de seine maritime membres de
la nuque ps qui votera la censure du
gouvernement
demain dans les jours qui viennent après
le discours de politique générale vous
avez déposé une proposition de loi sur
le pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée on en parlera raphaël
legendre journaliste économique l
opinion va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit effort mais d'abord qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans ce texte stéphane quelles
sont les mesures de ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat dont l'essentiel sera donc
dévoilée demain si j'ai bien compris la
mi blakowski pour nous le dire tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens yann bonsoir à
tout bon si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors là si j'ai bien compris le
gouvernement n'en finit plus d'annoncer
des mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat y en a tellement que récemment
on oublié ce soir et en même temps c'est
pas grave parce que si je les citer
toutes j'aurais pas le temps de toutes
les cités donc oui c'est vraiment fourni
dernier exemple en date le 1er juillet
il ya des millions et des millions de
français qui ont vu leurs revenus
augmenter mes fonctionnaires par exemple
+3 et demi pour cent sont pas énormes
enfin je crois qu'on n'avait pas
augmenté autant depuis 37 ans j'ai lu
accès augmentation aussi pour les
retraités 4% pour les minima sociaux
c'est-à-dire rsa de l'allocation adulte
handicapé minimum vieillesse tinseau
viennent à une dizaine comme ça oui et
pour bruno le maire la priorité des
priorités c'est de limiter à la fois
l'inflation des prix de l'énergie et les
prix alimentaires d'actes mans c'est ce
qu'il répétait encore hier mais on ne
pensait vraiment pas ne vous rappelle
que le bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz
électricité c'est jean castex ou
souvenez de jean castex dans une
première comme octobre dernier voyez
donc on l'avait déjà dans un premier
temps pour celles suspendre finalement
le 30 juin puis a été prolongée lit
banon c'est pas le moment donc ça a été
prolongé jusqu'à fin de l'année on s'est
un peu habitués à cette mesure ne se
donne un effet c'est important donc
l'électricité n'augmente pas plus de 4%
par an s'il n'y avait pas ce bouclier ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à 40% 45 % à 25 %
ça donne une idée que ça marche plutôt
pas mal bon bah sur l'antique à le gaz
et électricité gouvernement se dit bon
on va faire pareil sur les loyers donc
un bouclier qui devrait se mettre en
place des loyers croît et demi par an
maximum alors pas de bouclier en
revanche sur sur les prix du carburant
alors là non on regarde on n'a pas prévu
de bloquer les prix du carburant c'est
dommage parce qu'il ya vraiment un
accord là c'est vraiment un point sur
lequel il pourrait trouver du soutien au
gouvernement c'est la ristourne la
gestion de 18 centimes donc elle était
prévue jusqu'au 31 juillet elle aussi
allez hop une petite rallonge bruno le
maire toujours lui dit qu'on pourrait la
maintenir jusqu'à la fin de l'année la
part de bruno le maire oui si c'est
compliqué de faire la liste de toutes
les mesures pouvoir d'achat c'est
notamment à cause de ma mère qu'il est
gratuit tous les jours avant qu'une
nouvelle mesure de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat donc par exemple hier c'était le
chèque pour les plus modestes pour ceux
qui doivent travailler en voiture on
écoute son idée c'est une indemnisation
qui concernerait tous ceux qui
travaillent tous ceux qui sont obligés
de prendre leur voiture pour aller
travailler est évidemment en fonction du
niveau de revenu ensuite il faudra
discuter avec le parlement c'est tout
l'intérêt de la discussion avec les
parlementaires de voir jusqu'où nous
allons est-ce que nous allons jeu coûte
4ème 5ème 6ème décide comme on dit
techniquement ce qui gagne 1500 1600
1800 tout ça doit faire l'objet d'une
discussion était parlementaire oui c'est
la constance changement avant pour fixer
un seuil 1500 1600 1800 un coup de fil à
l'elysée on prend l'arbitrage et puis
voilà hélas non c'est plus pareil
maintenant il va falloir aussi avoir
l'aval du parlement et c'est là que ça
se complique et carrément un sans parler
de la nuit pèse qui a déjà préparé sa
motion de censure il ya pas non plus une
ambiance très porté sur le compromis en
sommes enfin c'est l'impression que ça
donne en quelle est la tactique du
gouvernement c'est de se dire ça va pas
seulement je vais t'en parlement bien
sûr le vote du parlement et un essentiel
mais ça va aussi se jouer devant
l'opinion ce débat donc combres de nerfs
toujours lui qui sort une idée nouvelle
encore ce matin ses dires de les promos
sont limitées à 30 pour 33% il veut les
porter jusqu'à 50% ben quand il sort
cette idée qu'est ce qui fait il prend à
témoin les français et il dit alors qui
osera voté contre enfin le fait moins
bien que lui en écoute aujourd'hui les
promotions ne peuvent pas excéder 30 4 %
de remise dans la distribution je
propose qu'on élève ce seuil à 50 % pour
qu'il y ait des prix cassés pour tous
ceux qui en ont besoin ils vont refuser
ça la france insoumise alors on ne sait
toujours pas exactement tout ce qu'il ya
dans ce texte parce qu'il sera présenté
jeudi
trouver des arrangements avec le
parlement le rapport de forces est
beaucoup plus équilibré donc dans le
bras de fer il ya un premier test là sur
ce projet de loi savoir donc c'est très
important ce premier test gouvernement
prouver qu'il peut au moins faire passer
un projet de loi dont l'argumentaire
côté gouvernement de toute façon il est
prêt c'est de dire si ça bloque ça sera
certainement pas de notre faute on
écoute et l'ebit à yverdon quand il
s'agit d'augmenter les pensions de
retraite pour 15 millions de retraités
plus de 60 euros net par mois en moyenne
je vois mal qui s'y opposerait alors
peut-être que certaines oppositions nous
dirons qu'il aurait fait différemment
peut-être que d'autres oppositions nous
diront qu'ils auraient fait - ou
peut-être plus et c'est là que nous
commencerons à discuter dans le monde
youri retour d'olivier ferrand aucun
regret pour gabriela taille
ont toujours est il qu'ils se
débrouillent bien là on sait comme lille
et cannes à l'aise à l'oral et donc il a
l'air dont nous expliquer que je suis
discuter pour bien s'entendre que ça
serait peut-être pas si simple il ya
débat merci pour ce papier piquant comme
tous les soirs stéphane j'aime tourner
vers les oppositions une fois n'est pas
coutume ça peut être facile aurélien
pradié de dire non à toutes ces mesures
dans quel état d'esprit vous arrivez sur
ce texte chez les républicains le même
état d'esprit que celui que nous avons
eues depuis cinq ans défendre les
français la seule boussole qui sera la
nôtre mais je pense aussi d'autres
oppositions sera de défendre les
convictions auxquelles nous croyons et
les mesures auxquelles nous croyons
d'ailleurs donc il ya des mesures que
vous allez soutenir revient sur les
lèvres dire lesquelles ce soir d'ores et
déjà adressé la première ministre notre
président de groupe au lit et marc l'ex
il ya quelques jours adressé un courrier
très apprécié la première ministre en
faisant état de cinq propositions
notamment sur la baisse des prix du
carburant de la taxe sur la taxe alors
durant là je vous demandais quelle
mesure de ce projet doit vous allez
soutenir on va venir je vous promets il
ya un sujet prévue sur les propositions
de l'opposition est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce soir quelle proposition
dans ce texte on a beaucoup parlé on
peut même si vous voulez vous les rêves
on les répète rapidement j'ai une
violente est lesquels vous allez
soutenir comprenait tout de même qu'on a
un petit sujet de méthode
voilà le gouvernement qui n'a plus de
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
et qui viennent nous dire c'est moi qui
propose et vous allez potentiellement
amendé dit c'est moi qui propose avec un
brin de menaces lorsque les deux
ministres qu'on a entendu tout à leur
pardon de le dire sont pas dans une
position de dialogue incroyable il va
falloir que le gouvernement se mette
d'accord avec le président de la
république où ils sont dans une démarche
de co construction on et auquel cas il
ne faut pas simplement imposer les
mesures et nous demandait de dire oui ou
non ou alors ils viennent vers nous en
amont d'après paraît intéressant parce
que la question de la menace
d'abandonner les éléments pour qu'ils
puissent le faire le gouvernement mais
si tout ça est une vaste mascarade d'un
rapport de force nous ne me reste
mascarade quand même là on augmente les
minima sociaux ont des gels le point n'a
ni le soutien de la mascara non je n'ai
pas dit qu'il n'est pas dit que les
mesures étaient de lamasquère d'accord
selanne et à la méthode qui consisterait
dès le début à nous menacer n'est pas la
meilleure mais une question nous avons
fait des propositions c'est très bien on
va y venir d'ailleurs on a un sujet je
vous promets on va le diffuser dans un
instant sur qui propose quoi dans les
oppositions sébastien jumel même
question avant d'en venir à vos
propositions est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire pour la nuit baisse parti
communiste des mesures que vous pourriez
voter dans ce texte d'ores et déjà on
sûr de campagne et donc on a été élu sur
un mandat clair
les fins de mois le début - ressemble
aux fins de mois la france qui travaille
celle qui se lève tôt le matin celle qui
a travaillé toute sa vie les retraités
ont le sentiment que c'est plus dur pour
eux que pour ceux qui font de l'argent
en dormant et vous avez emmanuel macron
qui lorsqu'il est à l'étranger fait le
zorro s'en prenant aux spéculateurs
disant qu'il va toucher au grisbi et
lorsqu'il rentre on veut des profiteurs
de guerre le profil est
vraiment prendre aux profiteurs de
guerre et lorsqu'ils rentrent en france
oublie de toucher au grisbi et fait
l'impasse sur deux questions majeures
pour nous quand tout augmente il faut
savoir augmenter les salaires il faut
savoir augmenter significativement vous
répondez retraite sur vos propositions
mais je
m'étonne on a un président de la
république et une ministre droite dans
ses bottes d'accord il fait comme si
elle avait devant elle une armée de
playmobil aux ordres mais le parlement a
changé savez vous que les français ont
voté ils ont choisi un parlement qui
n'est plus tout à fait le même que celui
que nous avions avant et donc nous ne
serons pas des députés au garde à vous
nous ne serons pas des députés en
opposition stérile ce blocage est
stérile où seront les députés portant la
voix de nos territoires et des habitants
quart de l'objectif de ce débat c'est
après de rentrer dans le détail voir
s'il ya des passerelles contre soit
possible sur le fond je sais déjà
raphaël legendre bonsoir merci d'être là
vous êtes un peu l'expert arbitre un de
ceux de ce débat journaliste économique
à l'opinion sur la méthode et je viens
vers vous dans un instant là la balle
est dans votre camp au fond toutes les
oppositions de droite comme de gauche je
vous dis vous vous y prenez mal la donne
politique a changé ici à l'assemblée
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
vous qui êtes dans la majorité
présidentielle
si vous pouvez considérer des gestes est
ce que vous pouvez dire ce soir avant
d'entrer dans le détail oui on va
reprendre des mesures d opposition
la première chose et je tiens à revenir
sur ce qui a été dit c'est normal que ce
soit le gouvernement qui fasse un projet
de loi fin jusque là on est d'accord les
mesures allons être présenté jeudi à 16h
il ya des discussions il ya des voiles à
des propositions qui sont faites qu'est
ce qu'on fait en connaissent aussi avec
des députés les républicains ont alors
fait à ce stade non mais à la sauce add
on a fait chacun
ça fait chacun dans nos groupes
respectifs vous savez je fais partie du
groupe démocrate donc on a fait nos
réunions et on travaille chacun aussi
sur les propositions qui sont faites
sachant que nous on souhaite vraiment
que toutes les questions sur
l'intéressement soit vraiment prise
prises en compte donc ça c'est la
tradition on va dire bayrou modem en
plus du paquet qui déjà de plus en plus
confié josé c'est pour vous dire que il
ya sept le projet ensuite qui sera rendu
par le gouverneur et j'ai envie de dire
après le parlement fait son travail qui
est de parlements jeunes collègues alors
c'est non
jusqu'où émules chez marathon c'est pas
commencer le débat de façon alors mais
c'est du baratin le projet est déposée
jeudi alors avec beaucoup de courtoisie
de respect le projet déposé jeudi alors
où nous parlons nous n'avons pas
connaissance autrement que par les
dépêches de presse de ce projet
reconnaissait il ya beaucoup de choses
sur lesquelles
l'arbitré par l'elysée est donc vous
êtes dans la spéculation et ce sera à
partir de jeudi
le mans terres qui sont énormément
respecté par le gouvernement qui
redécouvre les joies du parlement auront
jusqu'à samedi 17h pour amender le
projet c'est vous dire à quel point le
nouveau gouvernement se met dans une
logique de co élaboration de réponse
oui mais l'urgence savez il faut jamais
confondre vitesse et précipitation
vous avez bien démontrer votre
incapacité à répondre à la vie concrète
pendant cette mandature sinon vous serez
sur les cinq ans qui viennent de passer
après
non mais
il revient sur les cinq ans qui sont ben
oui mais fabien
les cadeaux aux plus riches
[Musique]
le policier qui vous donne vraiment
voilà une voie nouvelle voie à porter
rafale de gens d'où vous suivez ces
dossiers de très près à la fois sur le
fond mais aussi dans l'est dans les
coulisses qu'est ce qui se passe on est
étonné de voir bruno le maire égrainé
les mesures ce texte il va continuer à
évoluer ou on en connaît quand même les
grandes lignes aujourd'hui dans ce texte
ces deux textes car en réalité ce seront
deux textes un projet de loi 'classique'
un projet de loi de finances
rectificatif ont financé ces dizaines de
milliards d'euros qui vont être quand
même voter dans les prochaines semaines
pour le pouvoir d'achat
le montant global il est environ de 50
milliards d'euros si on ajoute aux 25
milliards qui ont d'ores et déjà été
annoncées par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre la flambée des prix de
l'énergie notamment et on a 25 milliards
de hausse du pouvoir d'achat par la
hausse des minima sociaux la hausse du
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires ou des
aides sociales qui qui vont être votés
donné le marqué par d'une nouvelle aide
ciblée pour les travailleurs modestes
qui prennent la voiture pour aller
travailler oui c'est une indemnité c'est
possible travailleurs ils vont passer ça
sent un peu l'usiné gatfi qu'ils devront
passer alors il faudra d'abord que le
conducteur fasse la demande dans un
fichier administratif qui sera ensuite
recoupées par le fichier des contrôles
techniques et du fichier des assureurs
automobiles autant dire que ça risque
d'être un peu compliqué mais vous avez
certains travailleurs qui en ont
réellement besoin qui font 50 5 km
dernière petite question on va voir ce
que pour être oppose les oppositions on
verra si oui ou non il ya moyen de vous
rejoindre deux lignes rouges ont été
effectués par le chef de l'état ne pas
augmenter les impôts ne pas creuser la
dette croisade est là non oui causse
clairement la dette c'est 55 milliards
on ne les a pas même si les rentrées
fiscales ont été abondantes l'année
dernière et cette année c'est un déficit
de 170 milliards d'euros qu'on va
accuser encore l'année dernière
l'argent
de la dette mais ils essaient d'avancer
sur sa ligne de crête de la réduction
par rapport aux pays bas la croissance à
notre création de richesse chaque année
des ratios de déficit de dettes qui sont
très regardée en europe aussi c'est un
sujet
op 1 cette lutte contre l'inflation
c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs ce matin à la dizaine de
ministres qui ont passé près de trois
heures à l'elysée autour de ces
thématiques
qui prépare aussi un hiver qui s'annonce
extrêmement difficile sur le point de
vue énergétique notamment on est déjà
sur un paquet énorme de 50 milliards et
vous voyez qu entre les différentes
parties et les différentes positions
politiques ça s'annonce déjà très
compliqué et ce qu'on cherche à merci
c'est d'éviter la surenchère puisqu'on
est dans une logique du donnant donnant
parce que c'est ça l'idée on va regarder
tout de suite ce que proposent les
oppositions baisse des taxes sur les
carburants blocage des prix alimentaires
hausse du smic qui propose quoi tour
d'horizon signée hélène bonduelle
la nuque frappe fort avec 18 articles en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat elle présente
même une proposition de loi sur
l'urgence sociale eux ont voulu faire
respirer les profits nous voulons faire
respirer les français c'est le sens de
la proposition de loi que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui parmi les mesures
phares bloquer les prix pour les
produits de première nécessité denrée
alimentaire produits d'hygiène carburant
encadrer les loyers sur tout le
territoire ou encore augmenter le smic à
1500 euros net par mois dès le mois
d'août nous préférons les salaires qui
créent des droits sociaux qui permette
de vivre dignement que des chèques
occasionnels ou des primes désocialisés
et défiscalisées laissée au bon vouloir
de l'employeur puisqu'on n'a pas de
niche parlementaire vous ça ne vous aura
pas échappé on va pas discuter ce texte
mais ce texte nous a permis déjà
d'avancé le travail pour faire ensemble
tous les amendements le patron des
députés aient l'air olivier marc l'ex
s'est lui fendu d'une lettre à la
première ministre avec les trois
priorités du groupe les lignes rouges
sur lesquels ils seront fermes bloquer
le prix de l'essence à 1 euro 50 le
litron diminuant les taxes baisser les
charges pour augmenter les salaires est
annulée la csg pour les retraités en ce
moment l'état voit ses recettes
augmenter
avec la tva sur les carburants c'est
insupportable que l'état s'enrichissent
sur le dos des français donc ce qu'on
demande à monsieur demers et de rendre
cet argent de rendre cet argent
français et pas de faire des l'aumône
d'un chat qui ici ou là pour ceux qui
gagnent entre temps étant la baisse des
textes pour bloquer les prix de
l'essence c'est aussi ce que propose le
rassemblement national c'était même la
mesure phare du programme présidentiel
de marine le pen nous souhaitons la tva
à 5,5 sur les énergies nous souhaitons
0% tva temps qui est de l'inflation sur
des produits de première nécessité à
chaque fois qu'on pourra fléchés de
l'argent rendre de l'argent dans la
poche des français on sera au rendez
vous on pourra compter sur nous à chaque
fois que ce sera du gadget à chaque fois
que ce ne sera pas des dispositions
pérenne h entre le gouvernement et sert
à nous enfumer vous ne compterez passion
de nombreuses propositions venues de
l'opposition sur lesquels le
gouvernement devra à présent faire des
compromis alors y at il des compromis
possible sur l'énergie et le carburant
parce que ça c'est vraiment un sujet de
quotidiens sur le prix à la pompe
aurélien pradié les républicains veulent
supprimer la taxe sur les carburants ce
qu'on appelle ati cpe pour faire baisser
le litre d'essence à 1 euro 50
aujourd'hui il est à plus de 2 euros est
ce que ça veut dire qu'on voulait
bloquer les prix surprenant parce qu'à
droite on a du mal avec voilà fait cette
mesure ne sonne pas forcément comme
traditionnelles dans votre corps bloqués
elle est pris en diminuant les taxes
c'est ça l'idée pas tout à fait d'abord
il s'agit pas de baisser la paix ici pe
mais principalement de baisser la tva
qui s'applique sur la tei cpe on a
aujourd'hui un système de taxation sur
les carburants qui est ubuesque c'est ce
qu'on appelle la taxe sur la taxe ce qui
fait le coeur de 60% du prix à la pompe
ce n'est pas l'inflation conjoncturel la
situation internationale du baril du
prix du baril c'est la taxe sur la taxe
est donc ce que nous proposons plutôt
que d'aller monter des usines à gaz l
invraisemblable qui ne fonctionneront
pas qui au passage d'ailleurs vont
demander à une administration centrale
un travail incroyable qui va consister à
distribuer des chèques à certains
français on est sûr que râler trous dans
la raquette d'ailleurs pour leur
permettre de payer une taxe qui elle
même est payé à l'état ce que nous
proposons c'est de rabattre la tva
d'abord leur délit cpe s'il le faut
davantage pour ramener le prix du
carburant à 1 euro 50 nous le faisons
déjà sur l'électricité sur le gaz donc
le blocage des prix comme on le dit
n'est pas un tabou
pas sur les prix d'énergie mais je veux
aller plus loin pourquoi est-ce que
c'est un sujet absolument essentiel
c'est un sujet essentiel parce que ce
qui fait
principal les deux principaux moteurs de
l'inflation pour nos concitoyens bruno
le maire a raison de le dire d'ailleurs
c'est le coût des carburants et le coup
de l'alimentaire et donc c'est légitime
que sur le carburant et l'alimentaire on
a une action très forte j'ajoute notre
poids aujourd'hui nous avons un défi
économique majeur qui va s'aggraver en
période inflationniste qui est celui de
pourvoir des postes vacants parmi les
postes les plus bas qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre pays vous avez par exemple des
aides à domicile vous avez par exemple
les avs ou les un e s agit
essentiellement des métiers qui
nécessitent dans nos territoires la
valeur de grand et de longs déplacements
si on veut donc ne pas rajouter à la
période inflationniste une sécession une
un arrêt pardonnez-moi de ses activités
et une perte de ces emplois il faut agir
chaque vous avec ça coûterait cher à
l'état vous l'assumez mais on assume
totalement et d'ailleurs dans le paquet
que qui est proposée par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui dont pardon d'insister sur
la méthode nous le découvrons dans la
presse c'est quand même vrai sujet si on
veut faire de la co-construction les
allemands dont on nous parle beaucoup
dans leur travail parlementaire ne
découvre pas en séance ou en commission
les projets de loi du gouvernement ils
sont travailleurs attendre à 17h au riz
mais c'est un don
si ça coûte c'est parce que c'est
nécessaire pour lutter contre
l'inflation et dans le paquet qui
proposait on préférera toujours des
taxes et le distribuer des chèques 10
centimes d'euro de ces 5 milliards pour
l'état donc ça va très très vite cette
question là au fond alors c'est pas un
blocage des prix c'est supprimer la tva
sur la taxe ça ça vous parle c'est une
piste possible où ce sera retour n'ont
rien parce que c'est ça la ligne du
gouvernement voilà le but c'est de
prolonger cette ristourne mais à terme
on voit bien que c'est pas c'est pas
satisfaisant non plus parce que la
difficulté comme pour tout blocage de
bris en fait la difficulté c'est qu'on
voit que ce n'est pas suffisamment
ciblés et qu'on a des mesures qui
vont s'appliquer pour l'ensemble des
français donc ceux qui en ont vraiment
besoin et c'est ce que vous disiez je
vous rejoins tout à fait sûrs notamment
les aides à domicile qui en ont en effet
déjà bloqué est pris avec le bouquet
tarifaire pour vomir sur le carburant
est bien parce qu'en fait c'est le
volume est pas forcément le même et la
finalité en plus ce n'est pas forcément
la même et là je crois que vraiment même
s'il est immense et des dispositifs qui
sont plus complexes les chèques ils
viennent cibler les blancs cristaux ses
sentiments mois en août et après il ya
une forme de chèques carburant très
ciblée c'est le reflet qu'il faille la
voilure et bien ceux qui en ont déjà
remplacé version non ah bah moi c'est la
façon dont je le perçois pas ce qu'on va
pas avoir les deux dispositifs qui
pourront être au cumulatif et qu'on voit
bien qu'il ya des personnes qui en ont
absolument besoin et d'autres personnes
qui peuvent s'en passer ce taux devrait
être prolongée en août il ya quelques
jours jusqu'à la fin de l'année en
réalité et en plus venir s'ajouter
l'indemnité câble long et après mais non
la ristourne de 18 centimes sur le litre
pour tout le monde pour les moins chers
de france il des ces contrefaçons
temporaire jusqu'à ce qu'on le soutient
sur sébastien jumel voyez que vous me
pardonnez moi pardon vous même qui est
dans la majorité n'avait visiblement pas
toutes les informations sur les
informations s et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé par cet acte ne comprends pas
ce que vous pensiez ce sera mieux lotis
vallée en vallée discret parfois vous
difficle aller voter mais on va vous
intéresser cette année aussi voilà parce
que ça va se jouer ici à l'assemblée à
présent c'est pas la laisser décoller
c'est une proposition à ne peuvent pas
être passé à jumet d'abord acton que
dans un certain nombre de territoires de
vie les habitants n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de prendre leur bagnole pour
aller bosser pour elle est soignée pour
aller se former pour aller respirer la
mer pourquoi parce qu'on a déménagé la
montagne
à la mer dit on à dieppe pourquoi parce
qu'on a déménagé leurs services publics
qu'on a pu toubib conte à metropolis et
les réponses et donc on a éloigné tout
de ses habitants et de ses territoires
de vie on a lorsque les abeilles bornes
et ministre des transports supprimer les
lignes de vie par exemple donc pas
d'autre choix que d'utiliser sa bagnole
donc pour cela ils prennent très cher et
donc moi je souscris et on porte cette
idée nous mêmes
de diminuer la tva sur les carburants de
bloquer les prix vous dites alors
l'expert va nous dire ça coûte cher il a
raison ça coûte cher mais vous avez une
solution dans le même temps 300
milliards d'euros de plus pour les plus
grandes fortunes françaises total ce
gars c'est total qui paye par une taxe
exceptionnelle
il s'agit
de son prendre spéculateurs de guerre
comme nous dit emmanuel macron de ceux
qui font de l'argent sur le dos des
français
y compris en spéculant sur la crise
deuxième élément venir sur un deuxième
élément sur la méthode bruno le maire un
peu comme boris vian vous savez quand
ils ne nous durée avec cette belle
chanson vient gudule viens m'embrasser
je t'offrirai un frigidaire anatomy
theft nous dit ce matin jeux proposent
des ristournes 1,4 à 50% et ce soir ils
rétropédale en vidant bon j'ai pas dis
vraiment ça s'est compliqué pourquoi il
dit ça parce que d'abord s'il fait ça
d'abord ils tuent tout le commerce de
proximité ce qui est pas neutre dans nos
territoires de vie et puis ça revient
sur la loi galim parce que pendant ce
temps là mais agriculteurs les
agriculteurs chez moi quand ils
commencent les négociations avec dan
vendent le prix du lait à 33 centimes en
début de négoce et à 40 centièmes enfin
négo donc si on veut en même temps qu'on
distribue des chèques ou nés comme
disait mon copain rufin asphyxié à se
fixer ceux qui nourrissent le pays des
agriculteurs les pêcheurs ce qui assure
notre souveraineté
alimentaire on s'y prendrait pas
autrement donc on bloque les prix on
bloque les prix augmentent les salaires
suppression voilà de deux taxes et ça
compte vous demander à total ou à toutes
les grandes entreprises gazières
je vais mettre les airs qui va vous
parler que de payer la différence quand
emmanuel macron et sa majorité ont
décidé de diminuer la pl c'est un
milliard d'euros pris dans la poche des
plus pauvres et dans le même temps
emmanuel macron supprimer 10 sf et
donner à ses amis 3 milliards vous savez
on a moyen de financer des mesures et là
sur les loyers on nous propose en fait
on nous propose quoi de diminuer
l'augmentation
mais ça fait de la hausse
il faut essayer de rester donc les
carburants juste quelques données
globales pour recadrer un peu le débat
parce que quand on parle de ces mesures
tout le monde devrait payer un euro
cinquante voire 1 euros 40 le litre des
carburants ça a été chiffré ces
programmes on va déjà m il faut se
rendre compte 50 milliards d'euros pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des français
pour limiter l'inflation qui en france
est la plus basse d'europe on doit quand
même le rappeler même si elle risque
d'atteinte 7% ces 50 milliards d'euros
de plus pour le programme des
républicains qui traditionnellement sont
plutôt attachés à l' équilibre des
comptes publics et les 55 milliards
d'euros du côté de la france insoumise
pour de l'argent qui partirait sur
l'ensemble des foncières dont bénéfice
pour google dont dans l'année qui n'ont
pas besoin de cette aide en réalité d'où
l'intérêt d'une aide beaucoup plus ciblé
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui on
est en train de financer des énergies
carbonées pour l'ensemble des français
qui n'ont pas besoin de cette aide en
plus d'en rajouter 50 milliards pour
financer des aides à des ménages qui
n'en ont pas besoin a dit répondait là
dessus
de la dépense fait beaucoup de choses
avec sakho désirs nos vous raisonnez en
comptable est pas en économiste et je
vous le dira d'abord vous venez de
commettre une erreur vous dites on
distribue 50 milliards à des français
qui ne ment pas besoin non pas du tout
dans les 50 pignard beaucoup en ont
besoin pour ne pas être aussi experte
dont une majorité n'ont pas besoin je
continue de la firme et une hausse de 40
à 50 euros scénariste de l'alliance
mensuel jours près reçu la paye ex même
si c'est toujours nous expliquerez à nos
concitoyens des classes moyennes qui
n'ont pas besoin d'être aidés et là où
vous commettez une erreur à mon sens ce
qui n'est pas la vision économique que
vous devriez avoir dû pays c'est que
dans cette période inflationniste
nous avons besoin d'avoir des mesures
qui sont des mesures exceptionnelles et
que simon ammann et 500 milliards
d'euros encore ie6 nous voulons mais
vous obséder pas sur les chiffres sinon
être efficace
si nous voulons être efficaces en
s'ancrant dans le réel il faut regarder
la destruction des emplois ce qui me
préoccupe profondément demain
des emplois l'année dernière et on
continue d'en créer encore avec un taux
d'emploi vous est théoriquement élevé si
vous voulez bien je vous parle de pas
seulement de votre réalité mais aussi de
celle que nous vivons dans nos
territoires nous avons aujourd'hui un
secteur qui est en grande tension celui
des aides à domicile pourquoi il est en
grande tension principalement parce que
les déplacements ne sont pas prises en
charge pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui des aides à domicile qu'ils
cessent leur contrat de travail depuis
plusieurs mois parce que le coût du
carburant de leur père très clair
je termine sur ça les milliards que nous
réinjectons dans l'économie sont utiles
pour maintenir et créer des emplois
c'est ça la boucle scène de l'économie
alors je voudrais qu'on avance un tout
petit peu parce que le temps presse
qu'est ce que vous pourriez reprendre
sur la question des prises alimentaires
on a deux groupes c'est très clair le
rassemblement national et la nièce qui
veulent bloquer les prix pour un panier
de de biens de première nécessité
là je suis désolé parce que je vais vous
faire la même réponse que sur l'essence
c'est à dire que bloquer un panier de
produits de première nécessité ça veut
dire que vous le bloquer pour tout le
monde ça veut dire que vous le bouquet
pour ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin et
là effectivement c'est absolument
nécessaire pour permettre à chacun de
pouvoir à la fois se nourrir et avoir
aussi des produits d'hygiène qui soit
disponible mais vous allez les blocs et
aussi pour des personnes qui n'en n'ont
absolument pas vous ciblés par le shaq
alimenta cc oui et je suis désolé parce
que je me rêve
mais la réalité c'est que en fait une
mesure qui est la même pour tous en fait
elle est injuste puisque au final on
vient baisser des dépenses pour des
personnes qui n'en ont pas besoin et que
le but c'est d'accompagner d'aider ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin vous parlez
des aides à domicile et il ya aussi la
difficulté de la reconnaissance de ce
métier il ya aussi vraiment lequel on
peut penser que le chèque et les
menteurs trafic pour des gens qui voient
les pâtes le riz l'huile augmenté de 10
à 20% ça sera suffisant c'est alors il
faut il faut bien cibler vous savez là
aussi il ya eu des discussions qui ont
été faites des propositions qui ont été
faites et c'est à nous de trouver des
solutions de façon collective même si ce
sera pas facile je vous la corde c'est
comment est ce qu'on arrive à avoir des
dispositifs qui soit à la fois bénéfique
pour nous concitoyens pour qu'il puisse
avoir un certain maintien de leur
pouvoir d'achat et qu'on puisse prendre
en compte aussi et vous en avez parlé et
j'ai aussi des agriculteurs dans ma
circonscription qu'on arrive aussi à
garder cet équilibre là donc sur les
agriculteurs vous êtes pour la
proposition après casse et de revenir
aux 60 commandes non non mais voilà les
charmes de l'assemblée nationale c'est
qu'à l'intérieur même de la majorité il
va y avoir il s'agit d'arriver à trouver
des consensus et je pense que l'on doit
protéger les agriculteurs et le pré
finale oui mais quand les nous ce que
vous le savez sur le chèque alimentaire
ce qu'on souhaite c'est que alors on a
priori avait plusieurs chèques ça
effectivement c'est à travailler mais
c'est qu'on puisse prendre aussi le fait
que tout à chacun a droit à une
alimentation saine de qualité local et
qu'on puisse permettre à tout à chacun
de pouvoir acheter aussi ce qui est
produit localement est passager mais à
ce stade alors évidemment fait à prendre
des semaines ce débat mais à ce stade
c'est non on n'arrive pas à voir là où
vous pourriez convergent écouter on
prendra tout ce qui est à prendre moi
vous savez quand on a en tête
les frigos vides les aides à domicile
ash les ouvriers en trois-huit qui ont
le sentiment que la valeur travail n'est
pas reconnu on prendra tout ce qui est à
prendre mais ça fait pas la maille
pourquoi je dis ça parce que quand vous
dites on prendra ce à dire que vous
voterez chaque article correspondant à
quelques mesures le dégel du tout du
tout ce qui est bouclier bon apprendre
comment voter l'ensemble du texte dès
le compte n'y est pas au moment où je
vous parle texte écouter deux secondes
le l'électricité fall énergie a augmenté
33 % nous nous propose de freiner
l'augmentation ses 550 euros de
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat pour nos
concitoyens j'ai les chiffres y compris
qui sont communiquées aux villes qui
assurent le déjeuner des enfants + 23 %
pour les steaks hachés +10 7% pour les
pâtes enfin ceux qui font qu'ils nagent
dans le luxe est calme et la volupté ne
vont pas manger plus de pattes parce
qu'ils auront une diminution de
je vais insister sur le fait qu' ils
font salles une majorité relative font
l'impasse sur la valeur travail
consacré leur vie à travailler et ceux
qui travaillent c'est une impasse
idéologique de leur smic réhaussé à 1500
euros je veux dire moi la question la
question alimentaire d'abord ce qu'il
nous faut pouvoir distinguer c'est
l'inflation justifier de l'inflation
spéculative et sur la question
alimentaire c'est un vrai sujet
commenceront à faire ce travail là je
n'ai aucun scrupule à sanctionner ceux
qui font du fric sur le dos de la crise
deuxième chose je suis hostile aux
chèques alimentaires parce que je pense
que c'est une perte de dignité le chèque
alimentaire ça une concrétisation ça
veut dire que ceux qui en auraient
potentiellement le plus besoin vont
devoir se présenter à la caisse du
supermarché et tendre leurs chèques
alimentaires pardon de vous dire que les
mesures techniques qu'on va mettre en
oeuvre elles ont aussi une réalité sur
le terrain et je ne souhaite pas dans
mon pays demain voire à la caisse des
femmes et des hommes qui parce qu'ils
ont moins de moyens que d'autres
auraient attendre des chèques
alimentaires le dernier choqué par
chèque
et bien moi je suis choqué par le shaq
alimentaire et je pense que beaucoup de
français qui nous écoutent le serait
aussi le dernier
c'est d'ailleurs une réalité
mettez moi de vous dire que cette
question des chèques alimentaires et
s'est posé beaucoup dans les
associations d aide alimentaire et ils
savent que ça fonctionne très mal dans
les supermarchés parce qu'il ya cette
perte de limiter un dernier point
c'est utile de faire baisser l'inflation
pour tout le monde pour ceux qui en ont
vitalement besoin et pour ceux qui en
ont moins vitalement besoin parce qu'ils
continueront à injecter de la
consommation dans notre économie c'est
aussi comme cela qu'on lutte contre
l'inflation on voit que à ce stade tout
commence et c'est pas gagné 6 0 on
aurait pu parler de falaise en quelques
mots pour conclure en fait l'heureux et
s'évertue à monter les négociations
annuelles cette année ont augmenté 3% en
début d'année des nouvelles négociations
vont s'ouvrir en fin d'année sur les
1500 euros ça passe pas non plus sur les
1500 euros ça je ne pense pas que le
gouvernement accepte effectivement
les messages les messages envoyés par le
gouvernement pour l'instant sur les
propositions et de la nuque et des
républicains c'est niet pour l'instant
merci on s'arrête là où commence mais
c'était passionnant de voir si oui ou
non vous pouviez voilà vous trouver
quelques terrains d'entente merci à vous
tous vous rester avec moi aurélien
pradié on va parler à présent de vous et
puis de votre famille politique vous
êtes perçu comme un jeune ambitieux mais
toujours fidèle votre positionnement
anti macron dur a pu surprendre surtout
quand on sait qu'aucun candidat de la
majorité présidentielle ne s'est
présenté contre vous alors vrai jusqu'où
voulez-vous aller on a plein de
questions à vous poser comme le montre
ce sujet portrait signé clément méric
si on vous invite aurélien pradié c'est
pour en savoir plus sur l'animal
politique qui se cache derrière ce
sourire de jeune premier fan de 4l et de
mobylettes à 21 ans vous débarquez dans
un paysage local dominé par la gauche en
battant votre ancien instituteur aux
cantonales à l'époque déjà la politique
c'est toute votre vie c'est une passion
je prends un plaisir extraordinaire pas
vous l'expliquer c'est comme ça là qui
aime sortir moi j'aime faire la
politique sur votre cv un simple bac et
une carte de militant ump prise à vos 18
ans à 21 ans vous êtes au quai du
conseiller général député à 31 ans
numéro 3 de votre parti à 33 ans vaut
modèle en politique sont andré malraux
georges pompidou et surtout jacques
chirac certains vous vois déjà prendre
la tête des républicains vous préféré
temporiser jamais je n'ai griller les
étapes jamais et je ne souhaite pas le
faire ni aujourd'hui ni dans les
semaines qui viennent la seule chose que
je peux vous dire c'est que je me sens
aujourd'hui un peu plus solide pour
mener des batailles auxquelles je
n'aurais jamais pensé par le passé
au-delà de vos ambitions il y à vos
méthodes dès 2017 vous êtes provoqué par
le président de l'assemblée car jugé
trop chahuteurs avec un langage parfois
fleuri les ministres viennent pas pour
passer un quart d'heure confortablement
assis sur un fauteuil ça leur fait du
bien aussi d'être chahuté la méthode
pradier c'est aussi une façon de se
faire entendre sur des sujets qui vous
tiennent à coeur comme les violences
conjugales une deux trois quatre
115 116 117
comptez jusqu'à la 117e morte c'est nous
rappeler l'absolue urgence qui est la
nôtre violences conjugales handicap
pouvoir d'achat vous vous revendiquez
d'une droite sociale et populaire qui
doit parler aux jeunes la jeunesse
justement cela fait 14 ans maintenant
que vous entendez l'incarner ma
candidature c'est la candidature d'un
renouveau politique d'une nouvelle
génération politique l'avenir de notre
famille politique ne se jouera pas sans
la nouvelle génération l'avantagé
nouvelle génération c'est qu'elle peut
plus facilement tourner des pages qui
sont difficiles à tourner pour pour
d'autres déjà en 2008 cette journaliste
vous poser la question quant à un
éventuel avenir présidentiel s'est pas à
l'ordre du jour ont déjà laissé naître
au conseil général puis on verra la
suite après alors aurélien pradié à 36
ans n'est-il pas temps d'assumer
pleinement vos ambitions
alors elle après des réponses à cette
question la présidence des républicains
tentaient ou pas tenté de continuer le
parcours d'un gamin du l'hôte qui a eu
beaucoup de chance qui les a provoqué un
peu mais qui doit beaucoup à la
république oui mais vous n'avez pas
laisser le parti alors en hockey
la question n'est pas le laisser un peu
moins lente la question est de savoir si
un peu quand même en réalité oui fait ça
me touche de voir ce chemin là parce que
pas pour par orgueil personnel mais
parce que c'est l'histoire pour moi de
ce que devrait être notre république moi
je viens d'un milieu qui n'a jamais fait
de politique d'un territoire qui
politiquement météo style et tout ça
c'est la république qui me l'a donnée et
donc j'ai envie de rendre la république
il ya des grandes causes une volonté de
changer la vie de mes concitoyens qui ne
me quitte pas est-ce que ça passe par la
présidence d'un parti politique l'avait
bertrand demande vous le dites quoi la
question c'est si ma conscience me
demande si j'en ai envie alors
l'hôtellerie en vie peut-être peut-être
parce que tout ce qui peut me permettre
de changer la vie de mes concitoyens de
porter des convictions au delà d'une
ambition personnelle ça compte ce n'est
pas vrai si on est peut-être le congrès
c'est à l'automne prochain peut-être que
ça deviendra un oui oui c'est certain
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 comment vont
les républicains sans langue de bois
je pense qu on est autour de 3
et pas beaucoup trop marrant c'est très
peu c'est très peu et je commettrais une
faute en ne lisant pas lorsqu'on aime
une famille politique lorsqu'on aime un
courant d'idées on doit être capable de
regarder dans le quel état il est le
drame de la droite républicaine c'est
qu'elle ne parle plus à personne nous ne
parlons plus à personne parlons plus aux
jeunes talents plus aux catégories
populaires et si dans nos
circonscriptions individuellement nous
arrivons à parler à nos concitoyens de
manière générale nous n'y parvenons pas
à cliquer responsable d'une faute
collective il n'y a pas une personne
plus qu'une autre je pense qu'on s'était
garé sur un chemin qui consistait à ne
plus traiter les problèmes quotidiens
des français ont considéré que c'était
secondaire et puis peut-être à basculer
vers un message qui était seulement
identitaire identitaire oui je lui
rendais à la ligne de laurent wauquiez
il faut le dire franchement parce que
selon l'avis identitaire conservatrice
lui qu'il incarne aujourd'hui la ligne
identitaire allez viens de loin la sueur
sur les questions de sécurité sur les
questions régaliennes je n'ai pas un
millimètre d'écart avec beaucoup de mes
collègues de la droite la plus ferme en
revanche ce que je veux c'est que nous
parlions aussi d autres sujets que nous
retrouvons gatling voulez vous que ce
parti se reconstruise je crois pas que
ce soit seulement une question de ligne
quand même c'est une question de
positionnement politique 6 2 mais nous
sommes capables de parler aux jeunes de
ce pays en leur disant que la république
c'est une promesse que si le travail
pourront réussir si on est capable de
leur dire qu'il faudra plus six
générations pour sortir de la pauvreté
si on est capable de parler d'écologie
si on est capable de parler à l'aide à
domicile qui aujourd'hui ne vit pas de
son salaire si la droite est capable de
parler de dignité d'allocation adulte
handicapé en classe sociale j'entends
beaucoup cette question là derrière
parce qu'il faut bien que ça corresponde
à quelque chose c'est vous croyez
logiquement c'est pas juste pragmatique
de paris aux gens et bien si je devais
choisir un mot c'est celui de la dignité
la dignité oui je pense que c'est sale
est d'ailleurs tout à l'heure pour le
chèque alimentaire c'est ce qui nous
manque le plus dans notre pays et c'est
ce chemin sur lequel la droite doit
aller on retiendra ce mot vous allez
évidemment écouté attentivement
elisabeth bornes demain dans l'hémicycle
pour son discours de politique générale
qu'est ce que vous en attendez
précisément jonathan d'abord une méthode
en réalité parce que on peut se faire
plaisir en disant nous allons
reconstruire on va discuter en veillée
longuet concrètement comment de tomber
moi je suis prêt à avancer sur des
mesures qui seront utiles à mes
concitoyens et concrètement on fait
comment si c'est pour se retrouver à 2
heures du matin dans l'hémicycle
bataille vous attendez dans le discours
des gestes précis je suis beaucoup de
sujets à votre endroit sûr scop vente à
s'assurer public notamment sur des
sujets au delà de ce que nous avons et
variés tout à l'heure nous avons dans le
courrier que notre président de groupe a
dressé la première ministre demandé à ce
que nos inventions sur la d conjugale
isation de l'allocation adulte handicapé
voilà un sujet qui n'est pas un détail
normalement ou les couronneries dollar
et bien pas sont des promesses et si
dans la semaine nous sommes capables
d'abord un accord sur ce sujet ce sera
bon non pas pour les républicains n'ont
pas pour la majorité ce sera bon pour
les français pas de vote demain est ce
que c'est si grave que ça franchement
non parce que le résultat était sûrement
attendu mais mais ça veut dire quelque
chose de mauvais démarrage comment
voulez vous commencez à gouverner ce
pays si vous n'avez pas la confiance de
ceux qui représentent les concitoyens et
je trouve qu'on s'habitue beaucoup dans
notre démocratie à des formes dégradé de
l'exercice démocratique c'est pas la
première on va le voir avec la chronique
mais ce n'est pas une gloire de ne pas
être en mesure de demander la confiance
autant vous voter la censure avec la
gauche ou par certainement pas dans une
période compliquée je pense qu'il faut
avoir des réflexes simples est-ce que je
suis favorable à ce que le projet
politique de la nuque baisse remplace le
projet politique de madame board non et
donc je ne voterai pas de mention
censure avec la dépêche je voterai
contre la majorité
relative contre sûrement la déclaration
de politique générale parce que je n'ai
pas confiance en ce gouvernement n'est
pas question d'aller mêlée mais voit ma
voix à celle de groupements politiques
qui n'ont pas mes idées un mot sur
damien abad votre ex collègues des
républicains qui n'a pas été reconduit
dans ses fonctions au gouvernement il a
fait l'objet évidemment d'une plainte
pour tentative de viol il ya une enquête
qui a été ouverte par le parquet vous
l'avez sûrement entendu lors de la
passation de pouvoirs soit ces boues
sont très forts avec dénonce des cadeaux
les ignobles et il dit chacun devrait
mesurer la violence inouïe pour un être
humain une famille des proches de telles
pratiques savamment orchestrée et trop
souvent sans discernement médiatique
savamment orchestrée et va très loin
c'est un coup monté je ne sais pas je le
laisse désormais répondre à la justice
de ces sujets c'est devant la justice
doit se se défendre j'en tire juste une
leçon général bien mal acquis ne profite
jamais
j'aimerais vous faire écouter à présent
sandrine rousseau parce qu'il ya à
l'assemblée un autre député sous le coup
d'une plainte pour
harcèlement sexuel cette fois c'est eric
coquerel élu la semaine dernière à la
tête de la présidence de la commission
des finances
alors moi j'ai à écouter son témoignage
très attentivement sur bfm lorsqu'elle a
parlé dimanche soir je crois
dans ce qu'elle disait il n'était pas
flagrant qu'il y ait des choses qui
passent le cadre de la loi ceci dit je
ne serai pas complaisante comme je le
suis avec personne et donc j'attends de
voir le dépôt qui a été fait à la
cellule et les filles dont je ne suis
pas membre et les conclusions que tire
cette cellule pour voir comment a germé
ce que quand on défend la parole des
femmes il ne faut pas appliquer le
principe de précaution mais je crois
absolument cet officier enfin j'ai aucun
doute sur sa parole simplement je
voudrais préciser parce que par exemple
la définition de l'agression sexuelle
est extrêmement précises c'est sur des
zones très précises du corps là
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas d'éléments me
permettant de décider il ya ce qui
relève de la loi et ce qui ne relève pas
de la loi et ce sont des traitements
différenciés aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
d'éléments me permettant de savoir si ça
passe le cadre de la loi donc pour
l'instant qu'un problème eric coquerel
peut rester à la tête d'accor se demande
à ce qu'il y ait une enquête et les
filles va faire cette enquête la cellule
investigation a priori va faire cette
enquête à l'issue de cette enquête je me
rappelle qu'à une plainte en justice un
qui a des étaient déposés en plus de
cette enquête au sein de cette
commission interne à rfi vous pensez
comme comme sandrine rousseau ou est-ce
qu'il doit partir on soit elle patauge
elle patauge parce qu'après avoir été
l'héroïne du soutien des femmes parce
que c'est un de ses amis elle
rétropédale c'est ça qui est scandaleux
dans ce que j'entends la alain brossault
ça fait des mois qu'elle nous explique
qu'il faut être absolument intransigeant
qu'à la moindre suspicion il faut que le
politique se met deux retraits mais
quand c'est un de ses amis ça ne vaut
pas et robespierre avec ces deux mêmes
pratiques il manque indéniablement très
part variable fovu rang moralité avec
ses ennemis et très tolérant avec les
hommes répondaient par eric coquerel
peut-il rester à la commission des
finances qu'il se lâche dette donc une
connaissance de ce dossier je dis juste
que si madame rousseau sa propre
s'impliquent les propres règles morales
qu'elle hurle sur les toits depuis des
semaines elle ne devrait pas bafouiller
comme elle bafouille aurélien pradié
seller à présent d'accueillir nos
affranchis vous restez avec nous pour
leur parti pris ce soir nous serons en
direct du xiiie arrondissement de paris
avec elsa monde un gamin on va l'avoir
oublié nationale et puis jean rémi
baudot qui sera avec nous pour nous
parler et bien du pari raté des
oppositions il nous dira pourquoi et
puis thibault et knock
va revisiter en archives les meilleurs
grands oraux des premiers ministres de
la vème république nous a franchi les
voici alors on va commencer ce soir avec
vous elsa les dernières coulisses du
groupe renaissance avant le très attendu
discours d'elisabeth board demain dans
l'hémicycle je te le disais devant le
bâtiment parisien du mobilier national
les députés renaissance reçoivent autour
d'un dernier verre pour au fond
l'encourager la première ministre avant
ce rendez vous majeur
oui on peut dire que c'est un rendez
vous à la fois convivial et studieux ans
pour ouvrir la session parlementaire
vous l'avais dit au mobilier national
les députés renaissance ont invité
plusieurs membres du gouvernement on a
vu franck riester le nouveau ministre
des relations avec le parlement yaël
brome privé qu'est la président de
l'assemblée nationale et la première
ministre elisabeth bornes également
alors on le sait ces députés ils sont un
peu inquiets devant cette situation
inédite vous savez il ya cinq ans il
était avec une très large majorité plus
de 30 soit 314 députés et puis
aujourd'hui ils ont perdu la majorité
absolue ils sont 172 dans le groupe il
faut donc inventer une nouvelle façon de
travailler alors devant ses députés
renaissance elisabeth borne à préciser a
rappelé qu'il y avait 21 députés
ministres façon de dire que l'assemblée
nationale était vu comme un vivier de
talents pour le gouvernement elle a
appelé à être soudé à construire main
dans la main elle a aussi conseillé aux
députés de rester attachés à leurs
circonscriptions ça c'est une inquiétude
des députés ils craignent de devoir être
très souvent à paris et de délaisser un
peu le terrain elle est revenue sur ce
vote de confiance ce choix de ne pas le
demander c'est un vote de confiance qui
ne disait rien elle parle d'une décision
concertée avec le président de la
république et puis elle a rappelé la
méthode une construire des majorités de
conviction projet par projet texte par
texte alors la présidente du groupe
renaissance aurore bergé indien petit
mot aux journalistes juste avant de
rentrer elle est revenue un petit peu
sur cette nouvelle méthode et on voit en
creux la lie d'attac ou de défense de la
majorité bien c'est m les oppositions
face à leurs responsabilités
écoutez aurore bergé elle était à mon
micro avec soraya là où ici mais je
crois que c'est un moment qui à un
moment de responsabilité pour nous mais
un moment de vérité pour nous tous aussi
les français quelque part et nous
entendu une perse en me disant voilà à
la fois on vous fait confiance parce
qu'on vous donne une majorité mais elle
n'est pas absolue et en même temps il
met en responsabilité les oppositions
comment est-ce qu'elles vont fonctionner
aussi avec cette nouvelle donne et à la
fin ça peut pas aboutir juste à du
blocage et de l'obstruction ça doit
aboutir à des compromis voilà cette
majorité n'arrête pas de se réunir jeudi
elle sera reçue à l'elysée par le chef
de l'état en personne et là c'est tout
ensemble avec modem et et horizons après
oui on le sait myriam même si elisabeth
bord menées et la chef de la majorité
emmanuel macron c'est celui qui compte
pour les députés de la majorité le
président qui devra peut-être expliquer
davantage sa nouvelle méthode après
avoir acté le refus des oppositions de
rejoindre son gouvernement
ça ce sera donc normalement jeudi à 19
heures avant cela vous le savez demain
discours de politique générale et puis
il y aura aussi avant ça et bien la
présentation du projet doit pouvoir
d'achat l'urgence pour le gouvernement
et donc pour les députés de la majorité
merci infiniment eisa mondain gava
discours de politique générale
évidemment à suivre en direct à 15h sur
notre antenne avec une spéciale
commencera une heure avant à 14 heures
avec avec brigitte boucher alors on
enchaîne avec vous jean rémy parti pris
politique se soit vous nous dites et
bien que l'opposition a bien bombé le
torse à l'assemblée mais surtout il a
manqué une occasion historique de
marquer des points revenons légèrement
en arrière lendemain des législatives
emmanuel macron est en position de
faiblesse malgré sa majorité relative le
président est isolé et il n'a pas le
choix il doit tendre la main aux
oppositions pour leur proposer une
coalition il ya des concertations des
tractations et puis rien statu quo
l'opposition reste dans l'opposition et
la majorité recherche toujours la
majorité est ce qu'il aurait pu en être
autrement et avec un peu de cynisme et
de stratégie politique ou ici les
oppositions avaient accepté cette main
tendue même sans y croire réellement
elle aurait pu forcer emmanuel macron à
descendre dans l'arène pris à son propre
piège le président aurait été contraint
de jouer le jeu et de tenir la promesse
d'amendé son programme je m'explique
droite comme gauche aurait pu dire un
maquereau chiche
vous nous proposez une coalition hockey
mettons nous autour de la table voilà
nos propositions qu est ce que vous vous
êtes prêt à lâcher il ne prenait en
réalité aucun risque la droite aurait pu
pousser les questions d'immigration et
d'économie les écologistes sur les
renouvelables et la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale par exemple
probablement qu'à la fin il y aurait eu
un constat d'échec mais la charge de cet
échec était partagée alors que là
emmanuel macron enghien il rend
l'opposition responsable des blocages et
en face on se débat sur la notion
d'opposition constructive qui n'est pas
très confortable je pense qu'ils ont
raté un coup majeur un coup politique
majeur mais il était un peu baroque
quand même ce scénario là non mais pas
tant que ça puisque en fait se mettre
autour de la table et tenter de trouver
des compromis discuté programme c'est
l'essence même d'un régime basé sur la
proportionnelle c'est ce vers quoi
devrait tendre nos institutions si elle
s'adapter à notre parlement et pour tout
vous dire plusieurs personnes au sein de
la majorité y compris à l'elysée m'ont
confié leur satisfaction et presque leur
soulagement que l'opposition n'ait pas
joué ce jeu là il avait de l'or dans les
mains ils n'en n'ont rien fait me disait
un membre de la majorité alors pourquoi
pourquoi ils n'ont pas tendu ce piège
probablement par manque de vision et de
stratégie
dogmatisme on a décrypté déjà ici à la
manière pourquoi par exemple les
écologistes français votent avec les
libéraux à bruxelles des textes qu'il
refuserait de voter à paris on pense au
paquet climat enfin pro lampard par
division les groupes d'opposition sont
un peu morcelé prenez les nerfs combien
de divisions sheller quand vous discutez
avec olivier marleix que c'est ce que
vous le présente donc deux du groupe l
air est ce que vous parlez avec
l'ensemble des députés de droite quid
des courants wauquiez retailleau etc il
est difficile de discuter avec lui
rappelle en même temps c'est la même
chose à gauche et c'est peut-être ce qui
va rendre encore plus difficile de
trouver des compromis dans les prochains
mois et bien un droit de réponse
aurélien pradié numéro deux des
républicains quelle erreur que m
pourquoi est ce que nous n'avons pas
fait parce que nous ne sommes pas assez
cynique vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs en
commençant si nous étions cynique et
bien cynique et stratège je trouve que
nous ne sommes pas cyniques n'ont en
réalité il ya une raison plus profonde à
cela c'est là le besoin de clarté de
notre démocratie tout ça peut nous
amuser nous distraire
mais ce dont notre démocratie a
profondément besoin c'est de clarté le
dépassement des clivages l'effacement
des clivages c'est l'apogée des extrêmes
et c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
lorsque nous refusons l'édile politique
nous ne faisons pas par facilité
dogmatique par sectarisme
le faisons aussi parce que nous avons
conscience que nous avons une
responsabilité de salubrité démocratique
ce que vous voyez là on fait monter les
extraits et je le refuse que la clarté
c'est ça ce que les électeurs n'auraient
pas pu vous comprendre non parce que non
parce que confondre les oeufs et les
autres c'est contribuer à faire que dans
notre pays les seuls qui incarnerait des
convictions clair sur l'alternance m une
audition c'est une multitude de 106
collectif mines les socialistes ont été
dans la collection ils ont gagné des
élections après nous ne sommes pas en
allemagne le mode de scrutin n'est pas
du tout le même l'organisation
institutionnelle n'est pas du tout la
même donc tout cela au fond on enfile
des perles ont ce plaisir avec des
sujets qui n'ont pas de regrets macron
les républicains vont renaître selon
vous c'est quoi le travail et edouard
philippe va pas vous faire disparaître
ne sais pas le travail qui pèse sur nos
épaules et de réincarner un mouvement
politique qui puisse répondre au peuple
al'inverse ou à la place de ce que les
extrêmes font ils font mal aujourd'hui
alors on va parler maintenant des
discours de politique générale et va
plonger avec vous thibault enoch dans
nos archives de l'assemblée nationale
d'abord cette question un gouvernement
qui ne demandent pas de vote de
confiance vous nous confirmez ce n'est
pas une première alors non je vous le
confirme ce n'est pas inédit un myriam
quatre premiers ministres en ont fait de
même avant elisabeth board ce fut le cas
regardons pour maurice couve de murville
en 1968 michel rocard en 1988 edith
cresson en 1991 et pierre bérégovoy en
1992 à chaque fois faute de majorité
absolue alors que nous disent les
archives qu'est ce qu'un bon discours de
politique générale alors ce sera demain
le 28e discours de politique générale
d'un nouveau premier ministre sous la
vème république autant dire que
l'exercice est rituelle balisé attendu
d'où la difficulté de le réussir il faut
à la fois donné sa vision dérouler son
programme imprimé son style et si
possible marquer les esprits alors à ce
titre on a tous vu un depuis 60 ans du
plus long discours 1h45 pour edouard
balladur en 1993 au plus soporifiques
pompidou en 62
marc ayrault en 2012 interrompu par le
malaise d'un député socialiste des
promesses dremeaux revenant en boucle
détermination race ble ment renouveau et
au final des critiques souvent sévères
trop floue c'est ce qu'on a dit de
jospin en 97 trop technique jugera ton
pour juppé en 95 bref vous l'avez
compris l exercice est compliqué alors
comment sortir du lot alors deux
discours sont quand même restés dans les
mémoires le premier d'entre eux c'est
celui de chaban delmas en 1969 c'est la
fameuse nouvelle société penser comme
réponse à mai 68 et au malaise de la
jeunesse le concept marqua les esprits
et c'était à la fois une vision et une
réponse aux attentes du pays autre
exemple de discours réussi rocard en 88
là c'est un style que le nouveau premier
ministre impose à d'un côté le
pragmatisme les députés entend dire
parler de choses concrètes de boîtes aux
lettres cassées d'ascenseur en panne la
vraie vie donc et en même temps rocard
su lui donner un souffle en témoigne
cette envolée en parts emprunté à martin
luther king écoutez je rêve
d'un pays où l'on se parle à nouveau
je rêve de ville où les tensions soient
moindres
je rêve tout simplement d'un pays
ambitieux quand tous les habitants
redécouvrent le sens du dialogue
pourquoi pas de la fête et de la liberté
merci de nous faire découvrir cette
archive que je ne connaissais pas de
michel rocard alors pour finir thibault
à notre discours est restée célèbre mais
comme le contre-exemple parfait oui sans
vouloir placer le discours d'elisabeth
bornes demain sous de mauvais auspices
difficile de ne pas penser à celui
d'edith cresson en 1991 deux points
communs une femme première ministre et
un gouvernement sans majorité absolue à
la tribune alors la première ministre
socialiste affirmé vouloir concertée et
rechercher des majorités écouter la
méthode sera celle de la concertation et
du dialogue avec tous sans préjugés je
chercherai avec vous les majorités les
plus larges
sans que personne
n est à renoncer à ce vilain
situation actuelle alors malheureusement
on le sait cela finit mal edith cresson
pendant ce grand oral sera chahutée
moquer même par sa voix trop fluette et
que des députés masculins prendront un
malin plaisir à recouvrir ce mauvais
départ lui sera fatale elle sera
remplacée on le sait moins d'un an plus
tard aurélien pradié il avait devant
n'est pas connue pour son charisme et
son art oratoire ça c'est une évidence
vous allez les des
pieds vous lui ferez pas de cadeaux
demain il ya aucune raison que je l'aide
elle est suffisamment grande pour
s'aider elle même et je ne lui fais
aucun procès avant même qu'elle est
qu'elle se soit exprimé la réalité c'est
que on a un peu oublié que la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale c'était un lieu
dans lequel on était là pour exprimer
une vision et je pense que c'est ce dont
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui je pense
pas que le premier ministre soit en
mesure de le faire mais ceux qui ont
réussi l'exercice sont ceux qui ont dit
où il voulait amener le pays et puis une
méthode je le disais au début de notre
discussion quelle est la méthode que la
première ministre va proposer en tous
les cas on s'exprime pas à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale comme on s'exprime
dans une sous préfecture
dans tous les cas les tic vous y serez
vous y serez aussi j'en suis sûr nous y
serons tous demain 14 heures brigitte
boucher aux manettes puis le discours de
politique générale à 15 heures et un
grand débrief d'une heure en direct de
19h30 à 20h30 avec avec moi et puis
toute l'équipe de ça vous regarde merci
aurélien pradié d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir regardé a
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
avec jean pierre gratien ce soit un film
sur la scolarisation des petites filles
dans les pays pauvres le choix de sa
retourner dans un village reculé du nord
de l'iran est signée il ya certes et
albi très basse par et alors
[Musique]